yeah welcome to this video and playing
well pile I got some some requests to to
play more tonight some really crazy
games against him really interesting
games so this time we have a real Lopez
she goin so we had some very sharp
openings before so now it's a much more
a much more strategical game okay let's
go here yeah we get a rillo past
position very close type of game I hope
that I'll find my way around this better
than him the other games suggested that
is more of a technical player so the
Queen side is completely closed
one idea for whitey and this position is
support a piece second see form getting
pass us but the pieces are very far away
at the moment so why is this playable I
thought this would be good the h-bond
seems very exposed okay if I take age
form
yeah I think it just blended this age
for what's the blunder net really that
move after that
Knight a5 I always need to be cautious
about about this idea wait wait wait
wait King hmm should I plate should I
have played this in some other way kingi
talking edge one
I still can play that I think on g4 i
still have night f4
he cannot play a 4G 494 so this should
should be okay
and yeah not sure f5 of course maybe
this is I know at five SS completely
completely bonkers why should I do that
ok let's let's reconsider text takes
Queen takes Queen age five heads could
could be an idea
okay therefore I can also just move the
Queen don't necessarily need to take
Queen f6 or queen e seven
yeah it's still it's still somehow
dangerous
putting putting pressure on the phone
yeah I can you can easily blunder this
game away that's black how to measure
something I mean he had one point at
nothing but he has something now
I'm not sure what f5 was was doing
doesn't doesn't really open the position
want to regroup
naija for this Thea diem
can first improve my position
hmm forgot about that
check check check time warning check
check check white foreheads okay whoo
yeah complicated complicated complicated
oh no idea at one point that was just a
pawn up but then he got caught like real
real compensation here it's just a pawn
but I am I managed to to to allow much
much much more play than that was that
was necessary yeah this was probably
still okay but but that I know maybe
ruka a shade or something I need to set
up the pieces differently the way it
went it was it was nice for a white I
mean maybe not not that he was better
word he has definite play this is no no
question yeah I after a five I think I'm
better again this is just now again a
porn because i have have this located he
somehow needs to keep the tension and
only maybe something like that I cannot
I can never really take because this
gets night f5
picture so what I need to do is to do
here I need to play some improving move
I know queeny's have no I don't know
something like okay you move me and I
have a hard time to improve here because
he has all those pieces directed towards
my king so he's got some nice play but
it's not easy for white as well he
cannot easily move the pawn year because
he always consists you five like in the
game and also let's say something like
this he can hardly play a g4 oh this
tragedy is good for what it was yep
interesting maybe g4 wasn't moves in i
was i would i would have taken i guess
with limited time check yeah this just
this is a mate i can i can do something
like that it but looks horrible alright
thanks for watching